già so per il fatto che sto gioco e
tradotto mi sto pagando addosso bene
tutti ragazzi e benvenuti a questo video
sono fa vigente su batterlo panthers è
un gioco di disegno ogni tanto mi
ritrovo a giocare a roba di disegno nel
mio canale c'è questa routine posso
disegnare bellissimo sembra una cacca
fumante tra l'altro come prima disegno
non è male vorrei trovare lì in server
per sfidare la gente a disegno capite
per questo gioco si fa online bene ci
sono dei server russi va bene ciao santo
gesù cosa sto
fermi tutti dove la dove l'altra che
vuole ecco qua sono nomi impronunciabili
di gente russa che beve vodka
ciao in italiano ha scritto per le
scogli credo che abbia capito perché
soste mille cose scritte a perché sono
le cose che dobbiamo disegnare in realtà
ragazzi dovrebbe essere un gioco dove
disegniamo gli uni contro gli altri c'è
uno deve fare il disegno migliore
dell'altro dobbiamo disegnare il tema ti
siamo tra l'altro una delle sette come
la mia fatevi segniamo il tempo questo è
il tè perfetto ma come fanno la la
madonna quanto bello l'orto aiuto aiuto
fa cagare io come si dice come si fanno
i colori come si fanno i colori 5 a
saperlo prima rega che ne so
allora facciamo sfondo verde il tavolo
lo facciamo marrone sappiamo fa sono
così bravi sti russi schifosi perché io
faccio pagare a disegnare non è colpa
mia o cosa vuoi dalla vita mia via via
le balle via dalle palle già difficile
porca vacca infame ecco qua questo è un
bel tavolo
aiuto aiuto questa è la gamba
il cosa devo fare devo votare il miglior
te il mio non è neanche in classifica fa
schiera ma dove hanno fatto sono bravi
questi questo dai il mio al mio e mi è
bellissimo il mio bellissimo il mio
bellissimo votate veloce grazie grazie
ma non posso con l'auto votar melo io ma
dai avuto da un cuore quella cagata 2
vi amo in finale in finale in finale
nota il mio ma termino tamino no perché
no il mio più bello se sia procederemo
di nuovo lo spareggio ancora ancora
volete il mio sì portate a sinistra
sinistra no no quello no non ci credo
per un attimo per una cioè per un attimo
avrei vinto io
brutto ma eletto raccomandato schifoso
chi è che ha vinto ci è mancato tanto
così anche la gai voglio il nome della
che tentò trovare questa stanza ai
understand e ciao ciao
ma secondo me è un'altra su cabli ed vai
boom che va bene
che ne so sixty seconds o come si fa un
bunker raga ma che ne so non riesco a
fare la scala non riesca a scendere
dritto col mouse a jesus a quanti
problemi ma fa una linea dritta
ok ora ga per fare la scala ci ho messo
un'ora per la scala e basta ok allora
questo è il mio bunker dai e qualcosa
non è male secondo me cosa scala che
scende che cosa sto vedendo il dio
grazie grazie grazie grazie a tutti
grazie a tutti gentilissimi ced ecco
cos'è quella roba in basso a sinistra
il primo turno lo passato il secondo fa
cagare hanno fatto solo degli hamburger
ce lo show down finale a mi sembrava
strano ma cosa voti l'hamburger e un
bunker non hamburger cosa votano
l'hamburger è un bunker non hamburger
morisse tempo a madre la tua famiglia i
tuoi cani che hai avuto anche che sono
sono morti devono morire quelli che
avrai tutti comunica i figli dei tuoi
cani i figli dei figli dei proprietari
che avranno i figli tuoi cani come
morire tutti tutti ma ora per disegnare
le gare i puntini ma tua sorella mortal
putrefatta in autostrada situazione cosa
vuol dire come la novi prego cambiate il
tema perché non ha senso come la disegno
situazione c'è una situazione aspettami
cercare la situazione attuale non mi va
bene situazione può essere una roba tipo
il sesso
allora questa potrebbe essere una
situazione
cosa vuoi tu non sbirciare vai via live
i che sbirciano ragazzi miei questo è
tutto ciò che ho potuto fare per la
situazione non sapevo altro che
cos'altro fare perché non capite non
sapevo mi fa piacere che vi siate la
pira fare anche voi io direi che la mia
stravince in questo caso quella in basso
a sinistra sembravano i miei grafici a
scuola non capisco perché c'è una sonda
su marte what quelle dovrebbero essere
due bocce perché due stelle il primo
vabbè ho passato il primo turno a no a
pari merito
fermi tutti non votate più niente
mi dispiace aver vinto con una cagata
del genere ma ho vinto quindi va bene
che gioca un brutto è che cosa mi
rappresenta questo videogioco ma che la
partita era andata al ci manca accesso
seconda avevo perso 30 secondi avvio
avvio ok prova a fare una cosa sarà
difficilissima ve lo dico ma ci prova
allora rosso verde no aiuto del casinò
blu e giallo ma basta sbirciare mio dio
fate le vostre cose santo gesù scriviamo
in bianco in inglese caricamento e si
iscrive in carica nello a thing tac
basta questo è quanto raga non so fare
di meglio che l'utente li sa che ha
fatto gli altri
una scarpa in queste quattro ball a una
holding il mio tutta la città tutta la
vita il mio dai buona stella
cosa stai cos'è cosa cosa mi cosa cos'è
quella roba grazie a il finale questo il
finale tra me una scarpa due stelle dai
lo fa mi dicessero con con situazione
raia troppo forte o gioco troppo forte
troppo vinco sempre io non c'è verso
ormai number one ed ero anche partito
ritardo perché ero accesso vabbè
cosa l'ha disegnato su tizio se qua la
competizione è questa ce l'ha un po nel
deretano però va bene ma neanche a mano
riesca come diavolo dovrà rappresentare
febbraio school spiega mi va bene oggi
si sa è una roba che non c'entra niente
vedere se prendo un
appunto almeno un solo punto la parola
disegna una paperella di gomma si chiama
la vasca da bagno che non c'entra nulla
ma va bene perfetto ora la paperella di
gomma
non riesco a fare neanche la paperella
di gomma figuriamoci come faccio a far
febbraio
[Musica]
effettivamente non so il senso di stato
a me lo chiedete per corte già difficile
averlo fatto offerte ammazzano cosa ho
disegnato santo acceso che brutta cosa
da riga o secco febbraio
queste febbraio aveva anche loro
effettivamente non è che c'entri molto
secondo me mi ha più bello a prescindere
accetta con febbraio non lo so vi prego
votate melo vi prego
e bellissimo anche la canoa non accetta
una sega però io mi astengo dal voto
come sempre io non voto mai niente
perchè questa non conviene votare gli
altri è l'aspetto che loro bottino
qualcuno ha voti qualcosa grazie
febbraio e vince febbraio migliore e
brut pirla cosa volevi far febbraio ma
va da via che meraviglia mi fate sognare
scemo mi chiavi segno pietro subito
pietro pietro pietro pietro da disegnare
un casinò era allora un computer
raga sta diventando veramente complicato
fare pietro però è un occhio giu
mi avete messo solo ma dai ma cos'è
l'ultimo della classe o mio dio quanti
pietro non ci sono qua va bene vediamo
vediamo che vado a quanto belli alcuni
cioè sono alcuni meno male che non mi
hanno messo nel turno con questi non era
meglio lui va la bava che abbia anche
michelle obama non lo so
a caso il mio madonna quanto bello velo
sopra è vabbè aveva affan correva 5 toto
regalo non posso vincerle tutte pazienza
e sta gente fa qualcos'altro a parte
giocare sto gioco 22 attenzione partita
giocatissimo è sembra molto più feltro
lui che quello che ho fatto io tra
l'altro io concludo qua raga con la
musica di skrillex sottofondo che ci sta
sempre o ne ho vinte almeno tre novità
se non sbaglio
e già qualcosa di cui una anche un po
spinta va bene per avis è piaciuto
ragazzi costo di ricerca momento mi
piace anche ai socialisti sel chiede e
noi ci vediamo l'anno prossimo di serie
a
pregate che non lo faccia molto presto
bella ragazza
a dovere ma auto inteso come macchina
spero
ragazzi di temi
la macchina più bella che abbiate mai
visto
[Musica]